every few generations we Americans are
called upon to defend our country to
defend it not so much from foreign
dictators or war or terrorism but from
those here who have no commitment to
progress or democracy or representative
government no commitment to anything
except their own out-of-control minds
and the bottomless pits of their egos
our society has thrown up these people
before Joseph McCarthy George Wallace
father Coughlin Jefferson Davis Aaron
Burr than Know Nothings the black
Lister's the America first errs and we
have always thrown them out and now our
generation has its own the most
dangerous individual ever nominated by a
major party for the highest office in
this country his base wants view details
and fewer facts they just want to burn
it down and blame their failures on the
collective other and Donald John Trump
is their demonic Messiah in
oompa-loompas clothing we must stop him
it is not pleasant it is not fair that
we have to do this but it is our turn
the average report in this series will
ask for about six minutes of your time
this one needs nearly three times as
much the text version includes more than
160 links I encourage you to read and
save because the emperor's new clothes
quality to the Trump campaign has
survived these 15 months because as we
react to each outrage our shock and
revulsion has been refracted like light
through a prism but these outrages are
not separate events not even a pattern
they are simply Donald Trump seeing all
at once they and he are horrifying and
you must see them all at once
thus in brief the story so far the
Republican Party has actually nominated
for president a man who attacked the
Pope who attacked John McCain for being
captured by the North Vietnamese who
attacked gold star parents kazeer and
Gazala khan and then juxtaposed their
names with the phrase radical Islamic
terrorism who attacked Hillary Clinton
as a quote bigot who attacked her as
brainwashed as unhinged as a monster as
the devil as the most corrupt candidate
ever showing her face on piles of
hundred-dollar bills and the Star of
David who attacked her as someone who
Second Amendment people should do
something about as someone whose
religion we don't know anything about
after he had explained he had never
asked God for forgiveness who attacked
President Obama and implied he was a
traitor who attacked him as having been
complicit in the Orlando terrorist
attack who attacked him for having lower
approval ratings than Vladimir Putin as
if Putin's approval ratings could
somehow be trusted who attacked him is
being born in another country who
attacked him as the founder of Isis then
said that was sarcasm then said it
wasn't sarcasm then attacked him again
as the founder of Isis who attacked
Carly Fiorina for her face Hillary
Clinton for her non-presidential look
Heidi Cruz for her appearance megyn
kelly for having blood coming out of her
wherever Mika Brzezinski as crazy and
very dumb neurotic not very bright who
attacked the women who accused Roger
Ailes of harassment who attacked the
women who choose abortion and who said
there should be punishments who attacked
a New York Times reporter because he had
a condition that made his arms look
atypical who attacked judge Gonzalo
Curiel
because he was of Mexican descent who
attacked senator Elizabeth Warren over
allegedly lying over her heritage to get
into Harvard when she never went to
Harvard who attacked Senator Jeff Flake
by saying he will not be reelected this
year when senator flake is not up for
re-election until 2018 the Republican
Party has actually nominated for
president a man who attacked US troops
in Iraq and claimed they stole millions
who has attacked Ted Cruz's father and
claimed he was connected to the
assassination of President Kennedy
attacked Bill Clinton and claimed he was
a rapist who attacked Mexicans as
rapists bringing drugs and crime who
attacked African Americans and claimed
they were all living in poverty with no
jobs and schools that were no good who
attacked Harrisburg Pennsylvania as a
war zone and attacked the United States
of America and claimed it is in a quote
death spiral the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who lied about opposing the war in Iraq
when there is a tape of him supporting
it a
tape-recorded on the first anniversary
of 9/11 lied about opposing the war in
Iraq during a speech in which he
insisted I will never lie to you who
lied about six million dollars in
charitable donations to veterans groups
from his telethon who lied about
donating his profits from The Apprentice
about charitable donations from the
Celebrity Apprentice from Trump the game
and to st. Jude Cancer Center who lied
about a plan to debate Bernie Sanders
for charity who lied about why he would
not release his taxes because he was
being audited and then proved himself a
liar by saying he would release his
taxes if Secretary Clinton released
emails who lied about how much money his
father gave him helping him to get out
of college who lied about sending his
private jet to ferry stranded US
servicemen who lied about talking to the
Attorney General of Florida who declined
to investigate Trump University after
she had been given a campaign donation
who lied about his business in Russia
who lied about meeting Russian President
Putin who lied about offering child care
to his employees when it was child care
for his hotel guests who lied about some
people wanting a moment of silence for
the murderer v Dallas policemen who lied
about seeing thousands of Muslims in New
Jersey celebrating 9/11 who lied about
9/11 hijackers sending their wives and
girlfriends home to Saudi Arabia who
lied about thousands of Syrian refugee
terrorists being secretly admitted to
this country who lied about the Chicago
Police urging him to cancel a rally who
lied about the Chicago Police saying
they could solve crime there with tough
police tactics who lied about how there
was no drought in California how he
never said Japan should have nuclear
weapons how he opposed the ouster of
Egyptian President Mubarak how the
unemployment rate is 42 percent who lied
about Isis making millions a year in
selling Libyan oil who lied about dozens
of secret terrorist cases in this
country who lied that a protester who
tried to rush onto his stage had ties to
Isis who lied last May and again last
week about refugees entering this
country carrying cell phones with Isis
flags on them and phone plans prepaid by
Isis
can you hear me now the Republican Party
has actually nominated for president a
man who congratulated himself in two
tweets and a press release for
predicting terrorist attacks like
Orlando while bodies still lay in the
pulse nightclub who congratulated
himself after the killing of Dwayne
Wade's cousin who congratulated himself
on predicting brexit even though three
weeks earlier he had never heard of
brexit who congratulated himself on
Republican convention TV ratings even
though those for his closing speech were
lower than John McCain's who
congratulated himself by disseminating a
video showing how much of that speech is
total running time was taken up by
applause who congratulated himself on
having the world's greatest memory then
three weeks later testified in a
deposition he had no memory of ever
saying that the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who has proposed that Russia or China
should enact a Watergate like hacking of
Hillary Clinton's emails who has
proposed banning Muslims from entering
this country then said it was only a
suggestion then proposed it again whose
running mate has proposed banning
members of other religions who has
proposed open racial profiling who has
proposed banning people from terror in
Asians saying look it up they have a
list who has proposed ideological
certification for immigrants who has
proposed worse than waterboarding while
praising how Sodom Hussein Vladimir
Putin and Kim jong-un handled protests
and terrorism who has proposed that
Americans civilians be tried by military
commissions at Gitmo whose proposed
killing the families of terrorists or
suspected terrorists a man whose
proposed teaching mandatory patriotism
in school proposed that his supporters
appoint themselves as Election Day
voting monitors proposed making American
Protection of fellow NATO members Zod
whose campaign proposed purging the
government of all Obama appointees
proposed avoiding government debt by
printing more money proposed reducing
national debt by paying less than we
agreed to proposed for stalling new
financial regulations by executive order
and
in the same speech proposed eliminating
some executive orders a man who has
proposed a wall along the Mexican border
to keep out undocumented immigrants
proposed mass deportation of
undocumented immigrants proposed a
smaller wall and fewer deportations
during a taped TV interview that played
at the same moment he was giving a
speech in Phoenix insisting on a larger
wall and more deportations a man who has
proposed immediately expelling at least
2 to 3 million undocumented immigrants
even though this would be like trying to
evacuate the city of Chicago in one day
proposed immediately expelling any
others not convicted but merely accused
of a crime a man who has proposed to
enact all this by executive action
bypassing Congress even though he
employed undocumented immigrants himself
in the building of Trump Tower even
though those immigrants say he not only
knew of them but hired them personally
even though his own modeling agency and
television shows enabled and employed
undocumented immigrants even though his
own wife may have worked here without
proper documentation even though his own
grandfather was reportedly not merely a
fraudulent immigrant to this country but
was also denied re-entry to Germany
because he was a draft dodger the
Republican Party has actually nominated
for president a man who claimed he
understood the sacrifices of losing a
child in war because he had spent money
to hire employees who has claimed he
understood prejudice against African
Americans because the system is also
rigged against him claim the election
will be rigged against him claim the
opinion polls are rigged against him
then praised one of the exact same polls
when it favored him claimed he would be
leading those rigged polls by 20 points
but four rigged media claimed Democrats
are voting ten times each claimed that
his crowd in Colorado Springs would have
been larger but the fire marshal was a
Democrat claimed that his speech in
Washington would have drawn as many as
Martin Luther King's I have a dream
speech but that nobody would let them in
a man who has claimed he was his own
best foreign policy adviser claimed that
Putin will not go into Ukraine when he
had already invaded you
crane in 2014 claimed the u.s. is paying
rent for a military base in Saudi Arabia
when the last one there closed in 2003
claimed that to avoid hacking the
military should stop communicating on
wires and returned to messengers a man
who has claimed that any candidate using
a teleprompter should be ineligible and
then himself began using a teleprompter
claimed that he does not use notes for
speeches during a speech he gave
primarily from notes claimed he will fix
the problems of African Americans and
then days later suggested that an
African American athlete protesting
police shootings should leave this
country the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who was revealed to have asked his
foreign policy advisors three times in
one hour why this country can't use
nuclear weapons if we have nuclear
weapons after having asked a television
interview the same question who was
revealed to have not known what the
nuclear triad was a man who has revealed
to have been the political beneficiary
of fake internet accounts underwritten
by the Kremlin revealed to have
improperly sought campaign contributions
from foreign nationals including
officials of foreign governments a man
who was revealed to have erased all his
emails including those sought and a
lawsuit for five years revealed to a
plagiarise twenty pages in his Trump
Institute and book revealed to have
employed the purported author of his
wife's convention speech which
plagiarized part of a speech written for
Michelle Obama by Hillary Clinton's
former speechwriter revealed to have
said on his 2008 radio show that Hillary
Clinton would make a good president a
man who was revealed to have admitted
using the pseudonyms John Barron and
John Miller while pretending to be his
own press spokesman and boasting of his
sexual conquests in the 1990s and
revealed to have use the pseudonym John
Barron while his company threatened his
undocumented workers revealed to have
telephoned one television network to
alert it to something positive being
said about him on another television
network a man revealed to have millions
in outstanding loans to the Bank of
China revealed to have tried to make
investment deals with moammar qaddafi
revealed to have once kept
a book of Hitler's speeches in a cabinet
near his dad the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who has allied himself with his campaign
advisor and delegate who said Hillary
Clinton should be shot by firing squad
for treason who has allied himself with
another campaign advisor who mused about
waterboarding Hillary Clinton who has
allied himself with an african-american
pastor who disseminated an image of
Hillary Clinton in blackface who has
allied himself with his own son who
follows a series of white supremacists
twitter accounts a man who has allied
himself with at least seven campaign
staffers who have disseminated racist
and or violent messages on social media
who has allied himself with a state
campaign co-chairman who tweeted Lynch
Loretta Lynch who has allied himself
with an Illinois Trump delegate who is a
white supremacist a California Trump
delegate who is a white nationalist
leader a former personal Butler who
wrote on Facebook that President Obama
should be quote hung for treason a man
who was allied himself with three
different campaign chiefs the first who
manhandled a woman reporter and then
lied about it the second who was listed
to receive 12 million dollars from a
pro-russia political party in Ukraine
the third who has been accused under
oath of anti-semitic comments and
domestic violence a man who has allied
himself with a foreign policy advisor
accused under oath of anti-semitic
comments with a new york state co-chair
who suggested kazeer khan supports isis
and is a member of the muslim
brotherhood with a close advisor who
says a Clinton aide could be a Saudi spy
or terrorist agent a man who has aligned
himself with a former campaign state
chairman accused of drawing a gun on
another campaign staffer with a
conspiracy theorist radio host who
claims the Newtown school shootings were
a hoax with a political operative so
corrupt he was once fired by Republicans
for falsifying evidence against Hillary
Clinton the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who has offered to pay the legal fees of
any supporter who becomes physically
violent against a heckler who encouraged
crowd
to harass and threaten a reporter who he
called out by name and who then needed
Secret Service protection who accepted a
military medal from an audience member
and said I always wanted to get the
Purple Heart this was much easier who
conducted a news conference to introduce
his running mate only to spend the first
twenty five minutes talking only about
himself whose prominent Latino surrogate
warned Mexican immigration would put
taco trucks on every corner four months
after the nominee himself commemorated
Cinco DeMayo by tweeting a photo of
himself eating from a taco bowl the
Republican Party has actually nominated
for president a man who tweeted thanks
to singer Billy Joel for dedicating
songs to him never realizing Joel was by
doing so mocking him who gave a trade
speech in Monessen Pennsylvania standing
in front of a wall man up bales of
compressed garbage who bragged during
the presidential debate about the size
of his genitalia who gave a TV interview
while seated in front of a photograph of
himself wearing the same suit shirt and
tie who appeared in a joint news
conference with the President of Mexico
with two bobby pins visible holding his
hairdo in place the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president an
irresponsible unrealistic naive petulant
childish vindictive prejudiced bigoted
racist Islamophobic anti-semitic
misogynistic fascistic authoritarian
insensitive erratic disturbed irrational
inhuman individual named Donald John
Trump this is madness
any questions